un village à vendre les habitants de
dompter en l'air une petite commune de
meurthe-et-moselle n'y vont pas par
quatre chemins la plupart d'entre eux
redoutent l'installation d'un parc
éolien sur les communes des communes
voisines ils craignent que les nuisances
visuelles et auditives fasse chuter le
prix de leur maison mais à part ce coup
de colère spectaculaire a priori ils ne
peuvent pas faire grand chose pour
s'opposer au projet stéphanie la fuente
jean-pierre pasteur sur place
dont taille en l'air à vos portes et un
nom prédestiné ici l'énergie du vent
n'est pas la bienvenue le village tout
entier est prêt à se brader pour éviter
l'installation d'éoliennes sur les
collines voisines delphine clabaut a
acheté sa maison il ya trois ans elle
vient de construire sa terrasse mais ce
paysage pour lequel elle a eu un coup de
coeur risque d'être quelque peu modifié
actuellement on voit quand même une vue
exceptionnelle surtout les vergers
mirabel ça et après ben voilà ça va être
gâché par theolia au total seize
éoliennes de 140 m de haut devrait
entourer le village mais comme elles
sont implantées sur les vents des
communes voisines dont taille n'a pas eu
son mot à dire sur le projet
d'ici les six de romain mais ont cours
ici les quatre de vesle ferrière qui ont
tour complètement donc les villages de
dons tailler d'haussonville
distance impact visuel niveau acoustique
nuisances pour la faune toutes les
études ont été menées par le responsable
du projet et sont conformes à la loi
mais ces expertises sont contestés par
les habitants
le promoteur égalé juge et partie dans
la mesure où c'est lui qui mène toutes
les études d'impact visuel par rapport à
la fonte par rapport à la flore par
rapport à tous les problèmes les études
paysages les études a liés à
l'appréciation de l'environnement sont
des études qui sont confiés à des
experts tels que les experts de l'office
national des forêts
85% des habitants ont déjà signé une
pétition contre les éoliennes et un
référendum symbolique est organisée ce
samedi mais la décision finale sera
rendue en janvier prochain par la
préfecture est fait